my dear brothers and sisters in Islam
subhanallah someone sent me not just one
person a few people send me a video of
Muhammad
and uh people telling me look the
enemies of Islam are using video to
bring doubt against Islam and I said
even I have some issues with Muhammad is
in Islam and doesn't mean because they
are using some of his videos we just
have to blame him because in Islam we
know they do miscuits and take videos
and clips out of context so I said let
me check it you know let me check it
it's my brother and Islam No Doubt you
know he has a right over me as a Muslim
even though I do believe it's open
misguidance no doubts about that you
know me Allah guidance and guide him but
I have to be just with him he's my
Muslim brother I have to be just with a
non-muslim let alone your Muslim brother
or sister
so when I've seen when I saw the video I
said no they're not taking out of
context they're not
and I'll play the video for you Allah
and by the way Muhammad is not the first
time he's doing this he did it with
yourself
Islam is called ignorance okay he's
trumpet for the enemies of Islam from
the orientalist and he did before and
subhanallah again
listen to this disgusting statement from
Muhammad hijab and guess the book of
Allah lion against the book of Allah the
Quran
you will get the indication that you can
have sexual intercourse of the
five-year-old the reason why it's Haram
to have sexual intercourse with a
five-year-old is not found in the Quran
at all if you just read the Quran it is
halal it would just it would be Halal to
have sexual intercourse chapter 65 verse
4. Allah tells us who you can divorce
and who you cannot divorce and then he
says
and the ones who had never been
pubescent before
and by the way this is very important
yeah
it looks of hand Allah
this is more lies this is disgusting
so the context president said there's a
context no the kofar they're going to
say yeah we understand it's speaking to
qurani but he's telling the Quran but
itself gives you indication to have
sexual intercourse with five years old
the Quran doesn't say that at all he's
lying he's mistranslating the verse
because he knew that the guy he's
speaking to his ignorance of Arabic
language so he mistranslated the verse
okay firstly I know Muhammad is tried to
do he tried to tell the Quran
you by the way their lies because if you
really follow Quran you have to foreign
but we don't have to go extreme to
refute them we don't have to utilize a
falsehood to refute the falsehood and
this the outcome of innovation is
guidance that's what they do
subhanallah so we as a selfish when we
start speaking out and get some brothers
that are still Muslim Brothers not
because we have personal issues because
we are saying they are refuting
Christianity but sometimes they are
using battle principles
or there are 15 atheists but they are
using false principles which later on
can backfire at the Muslims
so here you don't have to go the extreme
particular of income so it's argument
that if you read the Quran some
religious station you need more detailed
information which is in the Sunnah and
tell you to go back to all right and by
the way I did refute and exposed the
lies and the deception and the
misguidance of the so-called on you
check on our channel
so my as for this video today is about
this claim of Muhammad so
muhammadas and guide them in this evil
statement he said that is if you read
the Quran gives you indication you can
have sexual intercourse with five years
old then it goes on to sites a verse
from the Quran
he translated it as and so I speaking
about those who should who should
divorce okay
so he goes on to translate it as those
who has not reached the age puberty
basically okay he is not a term but the
meaning has not reached the HPV that is
a lie that's not the translation
mean those woman who has not have stayed
uh what they call it demensis
is not conditional for a woman to be uh
as puberty in order for her to uh is not
a conditional for a woman to reach the
age of puberty to have her mentions no
there's other uh ways to know if the the
boy or the girl reach the edge of
puberty one of them for the woman for
the girls Menses but it can be pubic
hair wet dream that if you mentioned
that even even from the uh with the
medical point of view but I can love
income so the Quran
he could have just sent to you
but we know
that can apply to a girl who is the age
of 17 18 because we know sometimes it
goes do have the Menses very late so
this verse does not indicate in any way
or shape or form
that you can have a sexual intercourse
with father yes oh where'd you get that
from
because because they don't have menses
doesn't say happy to hear Menses so why
are you like against the Quran yeah
you're more closer is truth than him no
doubts about that you're more close to
me than him no that is far away he's not
even Muslim to begin with but Allah told
us to speak with the truth your light
you deceive the person you use your your
Arabic language to lie to him and you
mistranslate the verse subhanallah even
because only said
maturity until they reach the age of
marriage
he can even say no news
said age of marriages
it means
subhanallah what is this so we have to
start light and guess the book of Allah
look making the book father look bad for
the sake of uh to refuse a button how to
build Muhammad may Allah guide us and
guide you yes we make mistakes sleep
with the tongue we forget no doubt about
that in the time of moments but but the
way you were saying it is that you're
you're so confident about it Brothers
let me tell you then he goes all and
starts speaking about let me get the
verse I mean the verse I want all
Muslims to be aware of this the reason
why we don't have sexual intercourse
with five-year-olds and six year olds
and seven year olds or whatever
is not because of puberty
wait a minute what did you say it's not
because of puberty because that verse in
the Quran
actually says they never had people
before you can't go around that the
Quran doesn't say
doesn't say anyone in the Quran that the
woman has to be pubescent I dare you to
find one verse in the Quran where it
says you're not allowed to marry someone
based on harm or you're not allowed to
have sexual intercourse based on harm or
you're not allowed to marry someone
based on puberty get me one verse in the
Quran which says the one has to be
people no you know in the Quran it says
it says you're not allowed to marry your
mom
where does it say you're not allowed to
marry him
I'm looking for one verse that you you
can say you pinpoint it and say this is
where it says prepubescent marriage or
whatever is not allowed so Israel Quran
alone you'll stay towards pedophilia and
a Severe type of pedophilia a wife abuse
you'll be leaning towards severe
pedophilia as severe
wife abuse okay kadab is a liar
well lies
indicate that at all whatsoever Muhammad
you're a liar you're better than the
other person no doubts about that but
you are a liar here how can you claim
that against the book of Allah where is
the other brothers are you gonna come
out speak out and guess him where is
your love for the Quran
so even Allah Allah told us
my roof be good to them even though
Allah to display Allah gave the
authority because the man is the leader
of the house and doesn't mean they
should be dictator okay because Allah
said
be good to your wives okay would Allah
give other stages how to deal with no
any wife with a rebellious wife
that she wants to cause harm there's
great arm that you're gonna deal over in
a specific way which Allah in the Quran
okay Allah
smack her step on her face firstly give
a reminder
even when I do you start using uh you
know what I call it discipline okay when
you just use a physical discipline Allah
after that what you do get her father
and get a mother
he never said and use even even Allah
said that doesn't mean beaten is a lie
so rather so we got all the Quran
together and you can understand because
sometimes some verses in the Quran
explain the other verses and sometimes
there's a certain extent other verses so
what you did here you're going to
extreme remember this video don't say
the scholar said this and that I'm
saying you cannot claim you have to take
back that the Quran itself
you will lean towards severe pedophile
and even the spirit isn't even Universal
defined what is the failure today in
Britain tomorrow will change and it has
happened already I'm gonna make a video
about inshallah literally a few days
back some people who got married the
girl at the age of 16 17 in this country
was allowed normal she was mature now
they're changed 18 therefore be those
guys they'll be copied or fives so now
look how crazy is and there's just
strength our points about the age of
marriage and which I will do a video
about inshallah to not make the video
longer Muhammad your life Allah and you
have to be honest with all the future
falsehood with a falsehood so there's
nowhere in the Quran it says and that
that you allow it to have sexual
intercourse with five years old and
diverse utilize your right against it